jeder bürger sagt die bayerische
landesregierung darf sich testen lassen
und bekommt in 24 stunden seien ergebnis
jens spahn herr söder kritisierte das
haben sie verstanden warum
nein zunächst müsse ganz klar wir haben
wir als staat den bürgern unheimlich
viele auflagen gemacht alles was wir tun
sind auflagen die konzepte abstand zu
halten
hygienemaßnahmen zu haben und
nasenschutz zu haben sind wie elementare
bestandteile des sicherheitskonzeptes
viele andere möglichkeiten gibt es nicht
und dann ist das einzige was der staat
eigentlich anbieten kann außer einer
guten krankenhausstruktur ein aufbau des
gesundheitssystems wir bayern werden
4000 neue leute im gesundheitsdienst
dazu anstellen ist daneben die test
kapazitäten zu erhöhen
und deswegen heißt es nicht nur
prioritäten dass das eine aber auch
kapazitäten
wir werden bis zu 30.000 tests seien pro
tag als als kapazität anbieten da
natürlich prioritär menschen mit
symptomen innerhalb von 24 stunden klar
dazu kommen die ganzen verdachts cluster
die wir haben wir haben sie ja vorhin
schon gehört dort wo es eher stärker
mögliches gemeinschaftsunterkünfte
beispielsweise oder bestimmte fälle bei
dieser fleisch betriebe und ähnliches
mehr natur
dann kommen aber auch die dazu die tests
möglichkeiten die wir für schulen
wir haben gerade auch den wunsch gehabt
von lehrerinnen lehrer bei einem kitas
erzieherin erzieher wenig anzubieten nun
noch nicht standard container konnten
dazu dass es auch sehr viele menschen
gibt die zum beispiel über die korona ob
eine information bekommen vielleicht
könnte ich da eine risikoerhöhung haben
oder jetzt nach dem urlaub
beispielsweise aus dem ausland die
zurückkommen und da wenn jemand sich
auch entsprechend fühlt oder glaubt dass
das ist dann werden wir auch ein angebot
machen dass man die chance hat einen
solchen test zu machen und ja wir sind
bereit ist auch mit zu finanzieren weil
wir sagen
der test muss möglich sein und zwar
schnell er muss für alle möglich sein
und eben auch kosten lässt gut werden
wir noch mal ganz schnell was sie sagen
und was der bundesgesundheitsminister
sagt
das konzept lautet schneller kostenlos
und für jedermann einfach nur viel
testen klingt gut ist aber ohne
systematisches vorgehen nicht
zielführend denn es liegt in falscher
sicherheit erhöht das risiko falsch
positive ergebnisse und belastet die
vorhandene test kapazität
jetzt sagt nicht nur jens sparen das ist
nicht mehr als eine momentaufnahme
dieser test unter welchen bedingungen
würde er in sicherheit bringen
also ein test sagt er nur aus dass ich
zu dem zeitpunkt an dem ich den abstrich
genommen habe negativ binder
das sagt man ja nix in die zukunft dann
weiß ich ja nur an dem zeitpunkt wohl
der abstrich genommen wurde das ergebnis
das heißt wenn ich tests machen dann
muss ich die auch regelmäßig machen das
macht nichts es bringt mich einmal nur
zu testen und ich muss natürlich dann
auch und das hat er so da ja eben
angesprochen auch bestimmte
risikogruppen testen oder eben in einem
cluster wo ich was vermutet wo bestimmte
bewegungen sind regel mehr das ist ja
sowieso klar und sie sagen aber wichtig
wäre die regelmäßigkeit und dann sind
wir bei herrn schmidt chanasit
der bundesgesundheitsminister fürchtet
es könne sogar mehr schaden als nutzen
wenn man jedermann testen würde also ich
habe diese ganze aufregung nicht
verstanden herr söder hat es ja eben
hervorragend erklärt worum es geht und
ich möchte mal dran erinnern dass wir
vor einigen wochen sogar unser mobiles
labor nach bayern schicken mussten um
die diagnostik zu unterstützen das zeigt
ja genau das problem dass wir in der
fläche schnell gute test kapazitäten
brauchen darum geht es es geht hier
nicht darum ohne sinn und verstand
massenhafte testen das hat denke ich
hätte auch nie gemeint und insofern
glaube ich kann man die ganze kritik
auch begraben ich sehe ja ein sehr
sinnvolles vorgehen zielgerichtet und
man kann hier nur noch mal an machen
dass das natürlich mit den kapazitäten
in den gesundheitsämtern eng verzahnt
werden muss weil was mache ich denn wenn
ich ein positives testergebnis habe dann
müssen die kollegen in den
gesundheitsämtern tätig werden also das
gehört zusammen aber wünschen würde es
sich eigentlich jeder 60 prozent der
menschen in diesem land sagen sie finden
es großartig wenn man sich testen lassen
könnte also dieser jedermanns test ist
das so ähnlich
wie mit den masten jeder reifen so lange
den nutzen weil wir so einfach auch
nicht es ist wirklich ein stein
massenhaften ansturms sind ja trotzdem
muss er trotzdem durch eine art zu
reinigen dann abgenommen werden
es ist einfach wichtig die schwelle
etwas zu senken dass ich eben nicht 50
kilometer fahren muss und dann nochmal
drei schwimmbad muss bevor ich den test
bekommen sondern genau das was er gesagt
hat schnelligkeit ist entscheidend
gerade diese super special events in den
griff zu bekommen und das ist glaube ich
genau die stoßrichtung dann fragen wir
die chefin von mecklenburg vorpommern
frau schwesig was sagen sie dazu würden
sie sich das auch wünschen und sagen sie
sie verstehen dass menschen das gerne
machen lassen möchten und könnten sie es
überhaupt bezahlt also ich muss sagen so
wie herr söder ist erklärt hat für diese
gruppen so machen wir es schon hier ist
es ganz klar dass jeder einen test
bekommt der symptome hat ist es ganz
klar dass wir testen wenn wie ein test
in einer einrichtung haben und dann das
ganze umfeld auch für die die keine
symptome habe aber nochmal jedermann hat
ihm gesagt und dann auch freiwillige
tests zum beispiel in bereichen der
lehrer und erzieher das haben wir im
land schon geschlossen
wir gehen auch in die fläche mit mobile
testteams eben nicht mehr starr an
testzentren sondern gehen wir haben auch
eine fläche in die fläche rein und bei
uns übernehmen auch alle
niedergelassenen ärzte jetzt die tests
so habe ich jetzt dann wieder verstanden
dass es vor allem darum geht da klar wo
symptome sind dass es sowieso klar aber
auch ohne symptome wo es aber eben
anders so gibt und insbesondere in
sensiblen bereichen das war bisher der
pflegebereich der gesundheitsbereich wo
wir mit freiwilligen test eingegangen
sind wie auch wir als land und auch wir
haben vor freiwillige tests zu machen
für erzieher für lehrer und wir haben
zum beispiel auch tests bei uns in
fleisch betrieben gemacht wo wir zum
glück keinen einzigen fall haben 500
testsiegel nacht kennen wer gleich nach
der sohn
ich wollte nur sagen also mehr testen
und das auch noch mal zielgerichtet
halte ich total für richtig und dass
herr söder noch mal mehr druck hat auch
angesichts oder mehr machen muss
angesichts auch der infektion sein das
leuchtet mir auch ein aber ich habe sie
zu verstanden dass es jetzt nicht so ist
das morgen sich millionen von bürgern
sag ich mal die testzentren überlaufen
sondern dass wir schon gucken in welchen
sie können die zielgerichtete testen
aber etwas auszuweiten müssen sie
richtig dann fragen wir bei herrn söder
noch mal nach herr söder 30.000 tests am
tag sie haben das eingeläutet mit dem
satz dass sie es für jeden ermöglichen
wollen heißt das dass sie es für jeden
ermöglichen
ja natürlich aber wir haben ja genau wie
ihr 5 und festgestellt wurde
nicht jeder geht er zum test nicht jeder
fühlt sich ja beispielsweise krank nicht
jeder ist mit möglichen kontaktpersonen
in kontakt gewesen
deswegen ist es auch von der zahl von
der schätze und die wir haben
hervorragend händelbar man muss ja eines
auch nicht vergessen es geht bei
bestimmten gruppen beispielsweise in
alten und pflegeheimen bei medizinischen
personal natürlich um die regelmäßigen
tests aber wenn ich dann so debatten
manchmal höher nicht in der runde jetzt
hat vielen dank dafür
sondern darüber hinaus na ja wozu
eigentlich testen das bringt er komische
ergebnisse es sind handlich debatten wie
man den usa hören nach dem motto test
mehr lieber nicht da bekommen ja die war
gar kein ergebnis
das hilft uns ja nichts wir haben zum
beispiel erlebt dass bei uns in ailingen
für eine größere cluster echt verhindert
werden konnten
manchmal sogar weil angebote für test da
waren und man festgestellt hat bei
jemand dass er der in einem bereich bei
einem spargelhof beispielsweise konnte
festgestellt werden dass jemand quasi
per zufall nebenbei wurde ist mit
getestet corona hat und so können
größere ausbruch szenarien verhindert
werden können fragen da schließen wir
uns in mecklenburg vorpommern an nochmal
beim urlaub das ist auch eine sicherheit
für alle
es ist nicht nur eine sicherheit für die
anderen urlaubsgäste sondern für den
betreffenden ja auch keiner möchte doch
auf dauer wirklich andere anstecken
insofern glaube ich gibt es schon auch
sicherheit und orientierung für die
gesamte medizinische versorgung frau
marinetti frage an die schriftstellerin
wenn 7
wie wir alle das gefühl haben dass jetzt
noch viel mehr verantwortung auf den
einzelnen bürger gelegt wird also auf
uns möchte man dann nicht auf der
anderen seite auch die chance haben sich
sicher zu machen also wären diese tests
für alle und die differenzierung habe
jetzt ja alle wohl gehört aber wäre ein
solcher test für alle nicht tatsächlich
ein gutes hilfsmittel
also ich höre mir das schon ein bisschen
mit sorge an weil was wie klingt das
jetzt eigentlich herr söder macht die
tests und sie sollen in dem bei den
bayern zur verfügung stehen finden nach
wie vor dass wir auch insgesamt lösung
für die bundesrepublik brauchen ich will
auch nicht diese konkurrenz dann
plötzlich die bayern ist ein bayerisches
leben eigentlich mehr wert als ein
schwäbisches sozusagen also ich finde es
eigentlich wichtig dass wir da auch eine
linie finden wie wir damit umgehen
sollen und die whu die empfiehlt solche
tests in der form zum beispiel nicht
weil sie auch falsche sicherheiten
vermitteln eben wie die kollegin sagte
man denkt man sei sicher hat sich aber
vielleicht auf dem heimweg dann doch
wieder infiziert aber passt dann weniger
auf als es gibt auch nachteile
mir wäre es wichtiger herr söder würde
ein bisschen das scheinwerferlicht auf
die problemfelder der korona krise in
bayern richten nämlich jeder zweite
mensch stirbt in alten und pflegeheimen
und damit ist mir so ein bisschen zu
wenig scheinwerfer licht aufgegangen wir
haben eine mortalitätsrate in bayern
ich glaube die ersten zehn bis zwölf
städte und landkreise der sind bayerisch
wenn es um mobilität von älteren
menschen den alten und pflegeheimen geht
wir sind da in bayern stärker betroffen
als die viel kritisierten schweden das
heißt was passiert in bayern eigentlich
in den wirklichen krisengebieten und da
verstehe ich auch die kritik von ihren
sparen wenn er sagt ja jetzt kommt man
mit so einem großen flächendeckenden
angebot klingt wie eine werbekampagne
wie toll meister bayern alles wir sind
die besten ist ja schön wir sahen wir
aber mir geht es eigentlich darum wo
sind die wirklichen krisenherde viele
menschen haben wir hier gehen die
maßnahmen verstanden sie tragen masken
sie passen aufeinander auf aber dorthin
zu gehen wo ja jeder zweite stirbt dort
dem pflegepersonal zu helfen was machen
wir auch mit der einsamkeit bislang ist
gibt
die menschen einfach zu isolieren ist
das eine lösung für alte menschen zu
sagen wir schützen euch in dem wir euch
isolieren also da fehlt mir einfach eine
problemlösung strategie die nicht so
glamourös daher kommt die sagt wir sind
test fähig wir können alle testen
sondern wo sind eigentlich die zentralen
schmerzpunkte der korona krise und wo
müssen wir hin wo müssen wir geld
ausgeben denn so test sind ja auch teuer
so fragen wir herrn wieder gleich aber
erst herrn schmidt chanasit nochmal wie
ist das mit dieser falschen sicherheit
in der wir uns wiegen
es gab ja immer wieder den hinweis
darauf dass man mit den tests eben auch
falsch positiv als negativ ergebnisse
bekommt ist das so also das ist jetzt
eine sehr technische diskussion und
genau darum kümmern wir uns ja als
labordiagnostik als theologen genau
diese probleme zu beheben
dessen sind wir uns bewusst und das ist
genau unsere aufgabe gerade wenn es
wenige infektionen gibt diese
falsch-positiven an zeit zu reduzieren
und das kann man eben durch sozusagen
ein bestätigungstest und weiter das sind
probleme mit denen wir umgehen und man
darf sich das nicht so vorstellen dass
einfach der bürger einen test
hingeschmissen bekommt positiv negativ
das ist ja ärztliche aufgabe das zu
erläutern zu erklären was sind die vor
und nachteile dieser testung also das
ist mir alles ein bisschen zu
vereinfacht dargestellt also dieser
arbeit läuft funktioniert insofern sehe
ich das nicht kritisch werden mehr teste
gemacht werden und wir fragen noch mal
nach nürnberg herr söder
natürlich war bayern so belastet wie
wenig andere bundesländer in diesem land
die berliner haben jetzt schon mal so
hinter vorgehaltener hand gesagt sie
finden es ein super plan ist das
tatsächlich auch ihr weg raus aus dieser
großen belastung und konzentrieren sie
sich genug auf die wirklichen
risikofelder ja ganz sicher
also wir waren am anfang tatsächlich
extrem herausgefordert wir haben
übrigens auch kantinen gemacht und zwar
komplett als ähnliche situation in wien
gütersloh waren beispielsweise im
landkreis tirschenreuth
es gab tage da war die situation
wirklich gefährlich dass wir
italienische verhältnisse bekommen und
wir haben es glaube ich mit vereinten
kräften und geduld unserer bevölkerung
geschafft das auf ein wirklich stabile
entwicklung zu reduzieren hinzu kommt
dass wir deutlich weniger der
einschätzung ist falsch deutlich weniger
todesfälle haben auf 100000 einwohner
umgerechnet 1 schweden deutschland aber
auch wir in bayern deutlich weniger
das heißt die schwedische strategie hat
leider kein deswegen gibt es auch dass
nämlich das kurz bitte erwähnen weil es
jetzt schon wichtig ist auch für die
zuschauer nur zuschauer das hat eine
ganz schwierige situation
sie haben vorhin zu recht gesagt alten
und pflegeheim ist wichtig keine
besuchsquote ja soll nicht passieren
umgekehrt müssen aber an die mortalität
denken man muss das schon praktisch den
ich nehme hier wirklich ganz bewusst die
pflegerin pfleger in den alten und
pflegeheimen in bayern sehr in schutz
sie haben großartiges geleistet in den
vergangenen monaten
da müssen wir wirklich dankeschön sagen
dass sie ihre arbeit getan haben unter
diesen schwierigsten bedingungen und wir
haben da eine menge gemeinsam auf den
weg gebracht wir geben auch dafür sehr
viel geld aus nicht nur das testen
übrigens ich habe vorhin schon erwähnt
wie rüsten das gesundheitssystem auf wie
viele bundesländer ist auch wollen aber
ich glaube uns immer gut in der zeit
gesundheitsdienst krankenhausbetten die
das sind und wir geben zusätzlich eine
menge geld das auch für
forschungskapazitäten unter steigert
zubehör ist bei kindern oder
jugendlichen ist und in anderen bürgern
also lassen sie sich das noch mal das
sagen vor sie würden natürlich die
sendezeit komprimieren aber bei solchen
punkten jetzt um leben oder tod geht
dann muss man das schon mal sagen der
ins leere und ist schade
danke an alle die mitgeholfen bei uns
sagen wir fragen auch nach erst bei
diesem dankeschön belassen können und
fragen jetzt aber frau teilchen um
nochmal zu diesen jüngsten hotspots zu
kommen wenn man sich momentan die bilanz
anschaut dann ist ein test unter 100
positiv zeigt nicht dieser fall turniers
in gütersloh das wenn man an den
richtigen orten testen würde dass man
dann viel mehr fände
also das kann ich nur unterstreichen
dass auch das was ich ja vorhin gesagt
hat wir müssen mit einem system testen
hatte müssen regelmäßig testen und wir
müssen genau gucken
wir testen und dann kann man auch über
flächendeckende tests reden
ich würde gerne noch anfügen zu der
diskussion die wir gerade hatten auch
außerhalb von bayern kann man sich
testen lassen auch wenn man keine
symptome hat auch das ist ja
mittlerweile geregelt es gibt eine
verordnung nach dem sich jeder testen
lassen kann auch wenn er symptomlos ist
und ebenfalls auch die menschen wenn die
eine warnung auf der app haben das
würden bezahlt
das ist noch mal wichtig glaube ich das
zu sagen sonst haben wir hier so das
gefühl
bayern ist anders als der rest der
republik nein das genau